parmi les percées historiques des
libéraux jeudi soir on compte l'élection
de quatre députés en alberta du jamais
vu à calgary depuis 1968
ludovic bourdages nous présente le de
ces nouveaux députés
portés par la vague libérale le député
de calgary-centre 15h et un visage connu
en alberta il a confié pendant la
campagne que tout dans son parcours la
préparer à représenter cette
circonscription à ottawa dans sa
jeunesse 4 était un joueur de hockey
élite mais sa vie a basculé le soir où
il a été atteint par balle lors d'une
fusillade à bord d'une voiture mais son
handicap ne l'a pas empêché de
travailler pour un grand cabinet
d'avocats et d'être élu en 2008 à
l'assemblée législative de l'alberta au
sein de l'opposition officielle
d'abord dans un caucus de neuf députés
puis 5 en 2012 ce sera donc sa première
expérience au sein d'un gouvernement
majoritaire
durant sa carrière en politique
provinciale il a été tour à tour porte
parole en matière de justice de finances
et d'éducation postsecondaire il blague
que c'est sans doute ce qui a mis les
électeurs de calgary-centre en confiance
et contribué à son élection
ses partisans soulignent que ce sont ces
qualités d'accessibilité de proximité
avec la communauté son attachement pour
calgary et son travail acharné qui ont
fait son succès sera le troisième député
en fauteuil roulant à faire son entrée à
la chambre des communes
et certains observateurs avancent même
qu'il pourrait être ministre